cuál es el valor del enésimo número en
la siguiente sucesión y nos dan esta
sucesión que vale 6 en el primer término
9 en el segundo término 2 en el tercero
15 en el cuarto y así consecutivamente y
lo que tenemos que hacer es encontrar
una fórmula general para los términos de
esta sucesión de manera que podamos
describir al enésimo número a partir de
simplemente conocer n entonces veamos
pensemos un poco en esto vamos a
escribir lo que tengo aquí son los
valores los valores que toma la sucesión
y lo que voy a poner abajo es el término
que les corresponde es decir en qué
lugar están en la sucesión el 6 está en
el lugar 1 el 9 está en el lugar 2 el 12
está en el lugar 3 el 15 está en el
lugar 4
y miren parece parece que van aumentando
de tres en tres porque tengo 63 es 9 9
13 12 12 3 es 15 así que ahí ya hay un
patrón porque no escribimos estos
números en términos de sus múltiplos de
3 es decir 6 es igual a 3 por 2 9 es
igual a 3 por 3 12 es igual a 3 por 4 y
15 es igual a 3 por 5 y si se fijan
parece que lo que está pasando es que si
quiero encontrar el valor de un término
entonces lo que hago es tomó el número
que le corresponde a ese término le sumo
uno y lo multiplicó por 36 es uno más
uno que es 2 por 39 es dos más uno que
es 3 por 3 12 es tres más uno que es 4
por 3 15 es cuatro más uno que es 5 por
3 entonces podríamos decir que el
enésimo término el término que está en
el lugar n en la sucesión
a hacer 3 x
n + 1 como el número en lugar del
término que s n le sumó 1 y lo
multiplicó por 3 u otro modo escribirlo
sería si si distribuyó el 3 podría
escribirlo como 3 n 3 y esta es la
fórmula que yo digo que si se mantiene
este patrón daría el enésimo número y
sólo tenemos que checar que funcione
para todos 6 es igual a 3 por 13 9 es
igual a 3 por 2 + 3 12 es igual a 3 x 3
+ 3 y 15 es igual a 3 por 4 más
3 así que esto funciona